Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
So, Sharks, who's
ready to suit up?
I am going to be the next
big toy brand in America.
It's been a journey,
but I'm -- we're all in.
There's a lot going on
financially
that really worries me.
The road of entrepreneurship,
it is full of heartbreak.
Our heart's
completely into this.
You've got
the courage.
That's why
we need experts
like you guys
to come on board.
Cuban: You have
a fundamental problem.
You don't know
what business you're in.
Oof.
I'm going to make you
a greedy offer.
O'Leary: That's outrageous!
Whoa.
Wow.
All roads lead back
to Mr. Wonderful.
I've heard that
so many times.
Unfortunately,
so have we.
Ahhhhhhhhhh!
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a snack inspired
by a love story.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kendra Bennett.
I'm from Longmont, Colorado,
and I'm here seeking $200,000
in exchange for
10% of my family's business,
Honey Bunchies.
Sharks, buckle up
for a true "Top Gun" story
with a tough-as-nails
fighter pilot
and an unstoppable love
for his sweetheart.
When my dad was an F-4 Phantom
fighter pilot in Vietnam,
he got by
on candy bars and cola.
He became hyperglycemic
and nearly diabetic,
which, of course, doesn't fly
when you're a fighter pilot.
That's why my mom created
a honey-based snack
that not only tasted great,
but gave him
a healthy source of energy.
Fast forward 35 years,
and Dad...
Hmm.
...tried to re-create
Mom's recipe,
but, Sharks,
he did
not
get it right.
He actually made
something better!
[ Chuckles ]
Dad managed to create a bar
that is completely unique
to the energy bar market.
42% of every
Honey Bunchies gourmet honey bar
is pure honey...
Mmm.
...mixed with crunchy nuts
and covered in lightly salted
and roasted sunflower kernels.
It's the perfect
honey-packed energy boost
that's gluten free,
grain-free, and soy-free.
And our coconut almond bar
is peanut-free --
and, Mr. Cuban -- dairy-free.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
We're changing the stale,
boring world of bars.
So, Sharks, let me ask you,
who's ready to suit up
and get on the flight line
with Honey Bunchies
gourmet honey bars?
[ Chuckles ]
Good job.
-Great job.
-Nice.
And if you don't mind,
this is actually
my dad's aviator jacket...
Cuban: Oh, that's cool.
...but it's really hot.
Very cool. Very cool.
Corcoran: Yeah.
Cuban: Can we try them?
Oh, please do. Please do.
Wow. Honey is truly
the main ingredient.
Coconut almond is good.
Thank you.
Wow.
It's really, really,
really good.
John: That
coconut almond's good.
Mmm, so yummy and delicious.
Not too sweet.
These things
are amazing.
Bennett: Thank you. [ Laughs ]
They're really good.
Yeah, they're really good.
And you know what?
My dad actually named
the bar after my mom,
who he calls "Honey Bunchy."
And they would have liked
to have been here with us today,
but because of my dad's PTSD,
they couldn't come.
So what year did your father
start the company?
So, he started
the company in 2010,
but he had no background
in food and beverage,
so the first three years was
just building the foundation.
But we started
retailing in 2013.
Our first major retailer
was Whole Foods.
We're in a total
of 1,200 stores now.
Greiner: Good for you.
We're in Whole Foods'
Rocky Mountain region.
We're in the Kroger banner,
King Soopers and City Market
in Colorado.
We're in Natural Grocers,
about 19 different states.
We actually do really well
in non-grocery, as well.
So, we have a lot of independent
shops all over the country.
John: What is the cost to make,
and what do you sell them at?
Our retail is $2.99.
Yeah?
It costs us 81 cents
to produce a bar.
What are your sales?
Year to date,
we are at $300K.
We expect to end this year
at $519,000.
And what will you make
on that $519,000?
We estimate about $22K.
But what's really exciting
is that, next year,
we're projecting
$2.2 to $4.2 million.
What?!
Such a large jump.
What's going to happen?
It is a large jump,
and there are five reasons
for that large jump.
Not six. Not six -- five.
Okay. Let's hear all five.
7-Eleven.
Okay.
Number two,
three nationwide distributors.
Number three,
a national retailer
that sells by the box,
not by the bar.
Number four is
the anticipated growth
that we're expecting online
because of the billboard
the first three
are going to create.
Number five is
our private-label client,
who is partly owned
by two world-known athletes.
So these aren't guaranteed
purchase orders.
You're just in dialogue
with them, right?
Actually,
7-Eleven is happening.
Is a purchase order
in hand,
and that's half
of the estimate?
It's as close as you're going to
get to a purchase order in hand.
It is the opportunity to sell
into all 8,500 stores
at the 7-Eleven annual
trade show in February, so --
Do you have that order,
though?
They had an application process
with 700 applicants
for their Brands with Heart
program,
which they are using to support
emerging brands such as ours.
We were in the top 1%
to be offered a free booth
at their annual trade show
to sell into 8,500 stores.
So that is happening.
We are going
to the trade show.
So, wait a second.
So they're not
guaranteeing you any sales
to any of the franchisees
or corporate owned, right?
Not guaranteed.
But, come on.
[ Laughs ]
I know how to sell.
O'Leary: You still have to
convince store by store...
Yes.
...or region by region
to take on the SKU?
I don't think
it'll be that difficult.
We'll be at a trade show. All of
them will be there in two days.
Ohh, I felt that way
many times in life.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they are skeptical about
Kendra's high sales projection
for her honey-based energy bar,
Honey Bunchies.
O'Leary: I want to
understand it. They've
approved the product.
Bennett: Yes.
It's now your job to sell it
into the regions?
They've approved the product.
We're already in
14 7-Eleven stores,
and we have proof of concept.
We know it sells there,
so --
Kendra, look.
Great product. I loved it.
They tasted amazing.
But the energy bar/
candy bar business
is brutally competitive,
and you're able
to run profitably,
put $22K to the bottom line
and continue to scale it,
and I know you want
to accelerate that,
'cause that's what we do,
put gas on the fire,
but it'll take so much
to get to a point where
there's a return for me.
I just don't see it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Kendra, your parents' story,
fabulous.
I -- I'm not personally
a big fan of honey,
and that's just
my thing.
Most of the world is.
But I have to love
what I invest in.
It's just
not right for me.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
You're such an optimist.
That's what makes you
a great salesperson.
It's your biggest
liability, too.
You're projecting $2.2 million
in sales next year.
Of course you're feeling
optimistic that you'll get them,
and I hope you do.
But you don't invest
on someone's optimism.
You like to see the fact
that justifies the figure.
I wouldn't be as far as I am
if I were
only
an optimist.
No, you're not.
We've been in business for --
You're a very hard worker
and an optimist.
But in projecting out,
optimists
tend to overestimate.
So because I don't have
that belief in the numbers
as much as you do,
I am out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Family businesses are often
tough for an investor.
Often, I find it challenging
to come in and disrupt
whatever is going on,
so I'm out.
Kendra, the amount of work
ahead of you is unbelievable.
Yeah. But you know what?
We are a hard-working team.
No, I believe you.
I believe you.
But, you know, you don't know
what you don't know yet.
But you can tell us
what we don't know,
if that is necessary.
We have stretched our own
personal money all this way.
I respect that,
but to take on an investor
with a valuation that's
completely insane at this point.
Well, then, make me an offer
that fits the valuation
that you're interested in.
No, no, I just -- It's...
Aw.
[ Voice breaking ]
This is...everything.
♪♪
It's -- It's everything.
We have put it on the line.
[ Sniffles ]
And we've been through
a lot of hard times.
I mean...
[ Sniffles ]
We took a huge hit during COVID,
and we pushed through,
we got through it.
I don't know how.
I mean, it was hard work,
a lot of tears and fighting,
but we did it.
We know we have
something special,
and I hear it every day.
People e-mail us
and beg us to never go away.
If you go and look at any of our
reviews, we're five-star rated.
Our heart's completely
into this.
[ Sniffling ]
Kendra, the road of
entrepreneurship
is not a destination,
it's a journey.
It is full of heartbreak
for everybody.
I-I gotta tell you, I don't
make emotional decisions
when I invest.
I make pragmatic,
factual decisions
because I have to deal with
what's put in front of me.
I can't take this journey
with you.
I'm out.
♪♪
I think you might regret it.
I think that you will.
I hope we do. I hope we do.
O'Leary: I hope I do.
We wish you
nothing but success.
Thanks, Kendra. All the best.
Thank you, Kendra.
Thank you. I appreciate
your time. Thank you.
Good luck.
Corcoran: Good luck to you.
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
I'm a little bummed,
but it's okay.
There's always a silver lining,
always,
so I guess
that's my optimist side.
But it's gotten us this far,
and we'll keep going.
There's no question.
It's very hard to say no.
I thought somebody was going
to cave and say yes,
and I was afraid
it was going to be me.
Very hard to say no.
The optimism,
as you said, Barbara,
is challenging,
because everything she said,
she didn't actually
technically have.
Oh, she believed it,
no doubt.
♪♪
Narrator: Earlier this season
in "Shark Tank"'s
first-ever live premiere,
we watched Nina and Sina Farzin
make a deal
with Barbara Corcoran for their
baby booger tool, Oogiebear.
So, he wants to go
to your summit, Barbara.
Yes, I want to go
to your summit.
Corcoran: Of course,
you can come into my home.
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
Corcoran: I only invite
my best entrepreneurs
to the all-star retreat,
because I want
to create a family.
They help each other,
they learn from each other,
and they go home
with a network of support.
I couldn't stop
pinching myself.
I was pinching myself,
and I was pinching Nina, too.
It was phenomenal.
In our seven years of business
before "Shark Tank,"
we were averaging $174,000
in product sales per month.
In the four months
since "Shark Tank,"
Oogiebear is selling
$410,000 per month,
and that is a total
over $1.6 million in sales.
To the bravest people
in the world,
stupid enough
to be entrepreneurs.
[ Laughter ]
With Barbara on board,
doors are opening.
Walmart has put us
in 1,600 stores nationwide.
We have the Oogiebear
with the light.
And then
the aspirators.
Corcoran: I was so excited about
the company from the get-go
because they had developed
so many new products,
so I knew they had the capacity
to keep inventing
and make a huge business.
We should have some fun
with the customers.
Let's do it.
And you just stick in the nose
and take all the boogers out.
The things I do
for my entrepreneurs!
Because you guys are fans
of "Shark Tank,"
we got something
very special for you.
[ Customers screaming ]
[ Shrieks ]
[ Laughter ]
What are you
doing here?
Barbara,
you are the best.
You know,
it's really important
to leave a lasting impression
on the customers.
And I know, today, we did that.
Nina: The first time
the idea came to mind,
it was so embarrassing,
everybody was laughing.
And now
they can't even imagine
how important
this tool has become
in helping
every parent out there
to improve the breathing
of their children.
So, to all those people
who doubt,
take your dream
and run with it,
because you never know
where it takes you.
We can't wait to see
where we go.
With the marketing genius
of Barbara
and the platform
of "Shark Tank,"
watch out, world.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a brand seeking to be
a better fit for all.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Charisse,
and this is my wife, Vicky.
We're from San Diego,
California,
seeking $250,000 for 5% equity
in our company.
When you go
clothes shopping,
Most stores have a men's section
and a women's section.
But, Sharks, neither of those
sections work for me.
The women's section tends to
have more form-fitting clothes,
which I like --
But I don't.
And while I love
the men's style,
those clothes are just not made
for my body shape.
Sharks,
she's got a booty.
[ Laughter ]
True story!
We're all unique individuals,
and we believe
the shopping experience
should be based
on style preference
and body type,
not on gender.
That's why we decided to forge
the future of fashion with...
Together: Dapper Boi.
A genderless and size-inclusive
apparel line
made to fit you
both inside and out.
Join Dapper Boi in being part of
a revolutionary solution
that'll bring confidence
within us all.
After all, isn't it about time
that we all fit in?
Sharks, in front of you
are some Dapper Boi clothes
we'd love for you
to check out.
Cuban:
Good for you guys.
Thank you. Thank you.
Good for you.
O'Leary: I'm really intrigued.
Corcoran:
This is a great shirt.
I mean, do you sell
direct to consumer?
Because you're asking retailers
to create a third category,
right?
Right, and, you know, obviously,
we're not opposed
to creating this third category
or not,
but, right now, we feel
like direct to consumer
is the way to go.
Of course.
Especially, you know, with
being a mission-driven brand
and just being easy
to shop online.
Good-looking stuff.
So, are you
blowing it up on social,
or how are you getting the word
out to your community?
Yeah, so Facebook
and Instagram, mostly.
We're excited to
start dabbling
into some influencer
marketing, as well.
How'd you
come up with this?
I used to shop in
the women's department,
and those styles
were just never for me.
I never felt confident.
I felt frumpy, I felt unseen.
But we started Dapper Boi
seven years ago now,
and literally it came
from a pair of jeans.
Jeans was the first thing
I tried on
in the men's department,
and it was the scariest thing
to go to that section,
you know,
to maybe be judged.
But it was exactly
what I wanted to be.
It was, like,
the confidence I wanted.
That was my style, you know?
It was emotional.
But years later,
I realized those clothes
just never fit my body type.
And so, we -- we saw
a bunch of people
just like myself
with the same exact problem.
So, I guess that your sales
are less than a million.
I think
they're over a million.
Please, let me be wrong.
Okay, so, lifetime sales
in the last seven years,
we've done about $3.5.
Good for you.
And, actually, the way
we've run our business
is preorder campaigns.
John: That's very good.
So, we bootstrapped
the brand.
And last year,
we were at $1.2.
Yeah!
Oops!
Yeah.
I got you.
So, why don't we get
into the margins?
What do you --
What's an average margin?
Take this shirt,
for example.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that shirt is $9.40.
Oh, wow.
And we sell it
for $60.
Landed price
for jeans, $15.
We sell them for $99.
Nice.
What did you mean when you
referenced a pre-order campaign?
How does that work?
Yeah, so,
how we were able to bootstrap
is that we launch
these products at what we call
"intro pricing."
So it's usually about
a 50% margin at that point,
and that really creates
a sense of urgency
within our customers.
Our repeat customer rate
is 51%.
Wow. That's huge.
These people are waiting
for our products
to come in.
And how do you execute that,
exactly?
I've never heard that.
So, we launch a product.
We put it out on e-mail,
social, everywhere,
and then the customers go ahead
and pre-order the product,
and we usually deliver
within 6 to 10 weeks.
But I will admit here,
COVID, you know, killed us.
Right now,
with the COVID delays,
we're seeing
6, 7 months.
Cuban: Ouch.
Wow.
And so how much do you have
in inventory right now?
60 grand.
Okay.
But it's across
a lot of sizes.
And that's
what makes it tough.
How much cash
do you guys have?
Uh, maybe $100 today.
$100?
[ Sharks exclaiming ]
What?
100 dollars?
I'm not -- Yep.
We're at the point here
where we just sold our house.
-Oh, no.
-Oh.
It's -- It's vulnerable
and not fun to talk about,
but we believe in this brand,
like, more than anything.
So far,
you're losing money, right?
Yes.
Okay. So, this --
How much money
are you losing?
Right now?
...on intro pricing
is killing your margin.
Yeah, wait, Kevin. Kevin.
How much money are you losing?
Yeah, so I think we're about
$150,000 negative this year.
What did you lose
last year?
$313,000.
So you're $450,000
in the hole, right?
Wow.
Yep.
Guys, something
doesn't add up for me.
Yeah.
Right?
Because your margins
are like this...
Yeah.
...and your shipping costs
shouldn't be that astronomical.
Right.
What happened was,
is I also started spending
in marketing.
I hired a consultant.
-Ah.
-Ugh.
Oh.
That's where you went wrong.
Yeah.
Vicky: Exactly.
So how much did you
spend on marketing?
I would say, you know, it was
definitely over 30% of...
Ooh.
John: Oh, my God.
So, you have
this rabid community
that wants to buy from you.
You don't need
to market them.
It was our attempt --
and it was a wrong attempt...
Yeah.
...to try to expand
and go further,
but we were not
ready for that.
And we will be ready for that,
but not now.
That's why we need experts
like you guys to come on board.
The reason why the people are
waiting 6 and 7 or 8 months is,
like you said, it's a community,
it's a movement.
It's funny that FUBU --
For Us, By Us --
has become used a lot
in the LGBTQ+ community.
Am I right?
Yeah.
And you are
For Us, By Us.
You know, that --
that's who you are.
Why are you trying
to go anyplace else?
If other people adopt it,
it's no problem.
100%.
But why are you
going anyplace else?
There's so many people that
identify with you right now.
Stop trying to be everything
to everybody.
No, you know, I have to --
I have to argue that,
and it's because I don't want
to be categorized.
I want to fit in
with everybody.
Listen, I'm pro-Black,
but never anti-anything else.
Yeah.
Right?
No, of course. Yeah.
It doesn't mean that
other people won't accept you.
Yeah.
So I have to be honest.
I have to give you
my assessment of the business.
I gotta try to find
a way to help you.
I'll mentor you,
but as for the business?
Appreciate it.
Yeah?
I'm out.
Thank you.
You guys,
I like to sit here and say
I've done a million products,
and I have.
And I've done something
in just about every medium,
but the one thing
I've really never done
is jeans, clothing.
I don't know how I could
bring value to your business
and help you out.
So, unfortunately, I wish you
good luck, but I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I understand your mission.
I respect it.
There is such a need for this,
but I think your problem
is much larger cash-wise
than you envision it to be.
Even if you came in here
and we gave you
the $250,000 for your stock,
that's nothing.
That's not going
to get you over the hump.
It's just --
It's a rough one.
So I wish I could be with you,
but I am out.
I wanted to mention
one other thing,
and it's pretty
important here.
We're about to do
a collaboration
with another brand
that does jeans,
and they do
3-D modeling.
So what happens with that
is that --
Guys, guys,
don't do that.
Yeah?
Don't do
the collaboration?
No. You have
a fundamental problem.
You don't know
what business you're in.
You have this community
that's like this.
Golden.
Your clothes
are not the product.
The community is looking
to your clothes
as their membership,
as the way for them to say,
"We all belong together,"
that, "This is us."
The clothes
are secondary.
It's keeping the community
together that's important.
But I have a fundamental problem
as an investor,
because we're not on the same
page on what makes the business.
If it's about,
"I want more inventory,
I've got
this collaboration,
I've got all these
other things,"
that's not the vision
I would have,
and it's your vision
that's far more important.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
You're not only all in,
you're all in 2,000%.
There's only one direction.
Yes.
It's up to the surface
so you can
breathe some oxygen.
That is not a wonderful place
for an investor to be.
Right.
I wish you guys
the best of luck,
but I'm out.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Thank you very much.
Keep on fighting.
Thank you.
Greiner: Good luck,
you guys.
Let me give you this.
Yes?
This is my number.
Awesome.
Good luck.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
-Thank you. Appreciate it.
O'Leary: Thanks, guys.
Alright.
Thank you, guys.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Vicky: I think
the Sharks reminded us
that our community
is -- is everything.
It's not the end
of Dapper Boi.
And you know what?
At the end of the day,
we came here to build
a relationship,
and I'm so happy
that we walked out of here
with, hopefully,
a mentorship.
Yes.
So that's huge.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is hours of playtime
in a convenient container.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kayla Lupean.
I'm from Cleveland, Ohio,
and I am seeking $150,000
for 10% of my company,
Play Maysie.
Sharks,
my daughter loves to play,
but as a first-time mom,
I was clueless
to the frustrations
that toys add to a household.
I was investing more time
trying to find missing pieces
than my daughter
was spending playing with them.
Not to mention, walking around
the house at night
was like navigating
a minefield of loose toys.
One wrong step, and bam, ahh.
I scream, she wakes up,
and I still have a house
full of toys to clean up.
Toys should bring joy to a home,
not mess.
That's why I created
Play Maysie.
Play Maysie is
a portable dollhouse
for quality play on the go
and less mess at home.
Our cases were inspired
by vintage tin lunch boxes
that open on both sides
to reveal
two interchangeable rooms.
Our magnetic floors
with attached wooden furniture
means no loose pieces,
no lost pieces,
and no more bottom-of-the-foot
owies for moms and dads.
When playtime is over,
simply close your case,
put them on a shelf,
stack them in a pile,
or hang them on a hook for easy
cleanup and all-in-one storage.
Whether you're planning
a long car ride
or just looking to clear
the clutter in your home,
Play Maysie keeps your child's
imagination active
and your cleaning to-do list
a little bit shorter.
So, who's ready to help me save
the soles of parents
all across America
with Play Maysie?
Great presentation.
Greiner: It's very cute.
So this is it
in front of us?
So, in front of you,
you each have a case.
Mark, you have our wild case.
I'm wild, baby.
[ Laughs ]
The wild case is
camping and fishing.
Barbara,
you have our home case,
which is a kitchen
and living room.
My favorite room.
Mr. Wonderful, you have red,
so it would match you.
Yes, I like that.
You could try it on.
Yeah.
And, Lori,
you have our cozy case,
which is a bedroom
and bathroom.
And, Daymond,
you also have our wild case.
Wild.
Well, that's kinda cool.
Greiner: Very cute.
Thank you. Yes.
It's like
a magnetic dollhouse, right?
Are there only
two characters?
So, there's a set of
six characters,
and it was really important
to me, two things --
to make this very
gender-neutral.
I believe that doll play,
especially for boys,
is very important,
and I really wanted everything
to be as inclusive
as it could be for the first
launch of the product.
My goal with this is to expand
the line of cases,
building out
the character storylines.
So, I just finished
the first book
that the illustrations
are almost done,
that is about each character,
and I want this to be a brand
where kids get to know
the characters,
love the characters.
I am going to be the next
big toy brand in America.
Aha!
Tell us about you.
Tell us your story.
So, in 2013,
I got divorced.
I moved out on my own
for the very first time.
I'd never lived by myself.
And I really invested
the next few years
in building
my photography business.
And so, I had dated
for a few years.
Nothing was working out.
And I kind of jokingly said
to my mom,
"Maybe someday I'll just adopt
and I'll do this on my own."
She worked at
an OB/GYN clinic.
I asked if anyone ever came in
looking to place their baby.
Wow.
She asked the doctor,
said it hadn't happened
in 25 years,
and the next day,
a couple came in asking
if he knew anyone
looking to adopt.
Unbelievable.
Oh, wow. That's fate.
-Wow.
And that's my daughter
on the front of the packaging.
So, it's really been
an amazing journey.
Christmas of 2020 --
I was a wedding photographer
previously,
lost all my business
with COVID.
And then, Christmas night,
I had this idea,
and I took my $25,000
personal savings,
built a Kickstarter.
Damn.
I filed all of my trademarks.
I did the provisional patent,
the website, an initial logo.
Okay, what does
it cost landed? All --
So, landed is about $13.
Including all
the components?
Including everything.
And that's --
And what do you
sell it for online?
I sell them for $49.99,
so we have about a 70% margin.
So, tell us about
the business.
Yeah, so I launched
my Kickstarter March of 2021.
How much did you
try to raise,
and how much did you
end up raising?
So, I had tried to
raise $25,000.
I ended up raising $30,000,
all organically.
I immediately took
that $30,000
and started the molds
for the tins.
I was short on money
for the production run,
so I sold my car.
We received the product
November 15th, and then
we ended up closing out 2021
with total revenue of $170,000.
-Wow!
Good for you.
And what are your
year-to-date sales?
So, I ran into an issue.
[ Laughs ]
So, I knew that I was going to
receive a purchase order,
and they wouldn't tell me
how much inventory
it was going to be for.
That's difficult.
But in order for me
to get it in time,
I needed to place the order
before I would know
the quantity.
So I ordered
5,000 units.
How much did they
wind up ordering?
So they only ordered
a few hundred cases.
Oh, God.
I did find an investor.
They invested $85,000 to pay for
the inventory and the shipping.
They took 10%, and it has been
the biggest blessing to be able
to get there.
Sales year to date,
I think, are $55,000.
And what do you think it will be
the end of the year?
I think I'll be around $400,000
at the end of the year.
$400,000? How much inventory
do you have on hand?
What is it worth
right now?
I have just over
9,000 units on hand,
and that's worth about
half a million in revenue.
Okay. I don't feel
like I've gotten
the -- the vision
of growth clearly.
Okay.
I like the product.
However, as for the business,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you so much, Daymond.
Kayla, this is very admirable,
what you've done, okay?
Thank you.
I'm out.
This is not
a business for me.
Okay.
Kayla, one,
quite impressed...
Thank you.
...that you didn't know
how to do any of this
and you created rapidly
a really wonderful toy.
But I go for
the three P's --
passion, perseverance,
and product.
And for me, you're passion,
you're perseverance.
But the product just isn't
the right product for me.
Okay. Okay.
I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, Kayla,
you deserve a ton of credit.
I mean, the adversity
you fought through.
But you're also
in a great position,
and I don't think you're giving
yourself enough credit there.
And if you just keep it simple,
you can have a business
where you're making $200,000,
$300,000, $400,000 a year,
starting next year,
and then look to scale.
Okay.
I think you're trying to do
too much too soon.
Okay.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Well, I appreciate that.
You're welcome.
I'm happy you saved
the best for last.
I don't think there's
a more adorable product
than what I see here.
It's well-designed.
It's well-thought-through.
Everything
packages so well.
But more important
than the business,
[Voice breaking]
you've got the courage.
Thank you.
You demonstrated the courage
all along the way
to be who
you wanted to be.
I'm so overwhelmed
by that, alright?
I think the idea that
you became a single mother --
1 in 100 women who say that
actually do it.
You went and did it,
and you deserve
the good luck
of finding your daughter,
of course.
When I was a little kid,
my mother invented this.
Her toys for the ten of us
were the Sears Roebuck catalog
where we cut out beds and plates
and sheets and made our houses,
and she painted
all the clothespins
that she hung the wash with,
all different figures,
and we played with it
for hours and hours every day.
I don't know why
they're not buying in,
but if they're not
buying in,
I'm going to make you
a greedy offer...
Okay.
...because I have
no competition.
Okay.
Okay. So, I would like to have
$150,000 for 30%
and $5 per portable dollhouse
you sell
until I recoup
my investment.
O'Leary: That's outrageous!
Whoa.
Wow.
Barbara!
Ooh, Kevin, how can you make
an offer like that, Kevin?
Oh, my goodness.
Would you be willing to either
go down to 20% with that deal,
or if we did the 30%,
would you be able to go up
to $200,000 for the investment?
I would give you $150,000
and another $100,000 credit line
if you keep it at 30%.
O'Leary: You know, Kayla,
it occurs to me that she said
all those nice things to you
just before she became a savage.
[ Laughter ]
No, not hardly a savage.
I've already given 10%
to another investor,
so that would only
leave me with 60%.
Do you know what?
I forgot about that.
Yeah, I'll take 20%,
but I want $7
per portable dollhouse.
It just doesn't end.
Until paid back only.
Deal. I'll take it.
It's a deal.
Cuban: The right decision.
Oh, my gosh!
Thank you so much.
[ Laughs ]
It's my pleasure.
You're my girl.
I appreciate it.
I am your girl now.
You know that, right?
Thank you. I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Ooh, I'm excited.
Thank you guys so much.
O'Leary:
Congratulations, Kayla.
This is like
a dream come true.
Congratulations.
♪♪
I created this business
for my family, for my daughter,
and every day,
I show up and work
to show her what is possible.
And today is just
the greatest example
of how far you're able to go
when you really put your mind
and work into something.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a food brand inspired by recipes
handed down from generations.
♪♪
Hola, Sharks.
My name is Hector Saldivar,
and I'm from
Tiburon, California.
"Tiburon" means "shark."
[ Scattered laughter ]
I'm seeking $500,000 in exchange
of 5% of my company,
Tia Lupita.
Oh, God.
Sharks, I'm going to ask you
for a favor.
Raise your hand
if you like to eat tacos.
Come on. We all do.
No tacos for you, Daymond?
I hate tacos.
Whoa.
Raise your other hand
if you like to eat
clean, simple ingredients.
Now try to touch your ears
with your elbows.
Nobody can do that.
You can't.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
Believe me, I've tried.
It's impossible,
just like it's impossible
for current Mexican brands
to bring innovation
and keep their authenticity
using artificial ingredients,
binders, and fillers.
Growing up in Mexico, we don't
inherit cars, jewelry, or money.
What gets passed down to us
are our family recipes.
Mmm.
Enter Tia Lupita Foods,
the better-for-you
Mexican-inspired food brand
that uses clean,
simple ingredients
that starts with one of the
world's most sustainable plants,
the cactus.
Cactus, or nopales,
is Mexico's sweetheart,
a low-glycemic superfood
that we use in our line of
grain-free tortilla chips
and tortillas.
Sharks, be prepared
to fall in love
with our five flavors
of tortilla chips.
They have all the crunch
and texture that you're used to,
but are packed with superfoods,
making them
a great source of fiber.
And we have two
types of tortillas,
a grain-free and cactus made
with upcycled okara and cassava,
and a corn and cactus.
Now, if you're wondering
why they're green,
it's because of all the dinero
we're going to make together.
[ Scattered laughter ]
At Tia Lupita,
we believe two things --
food is love,
and eating good should be easier
than trying to touch your ears
with your elbows.
So who's ready to make every day
Taco Tuesday in America
with Tia Lupita?
Nicely done.
Greiner: So, I have
some tortillas.
There's a bag here
of cactus tortillas.
Hot!
It's very, very hot.
And then there's
Habanero, Chipotle,
Salsa Verde,
and Hot Sauce.
Yes.
Oh, it's hot.
[ Laughs ]
You should have started
with a little Salsa Verde,
and then go into
the medium body Hot Sauce,
which is what we call the OG,
then Chipotle and then Habanero.
This is one of
the first iterations
of grain-free tortilla chips
that tastes good.
Thank you so much,
Mr. Wonderful. It means a lot.
The tortillas
are good,
and it's only 45 calories
for a whole tortilla?
Absolutely, yes.
Give us your background
and why
you decided
to go into your business.
I'm originally from
Monterrey, Mexico.
I moved here 18 years ago.
My mom, Lupita,
would ship me care packages,
like a regular mom does.
Now, granted, a regular
care package would be
a sweater or some socks,
maybe a little money,
if you're lucky.
My mom would send me hot sauce.
It's a family recipe hot sauce.
It had been passed down to
a single family member.
So I started sharing that
with friends and colleagues,
and everybody started falling
in love with my mom's hot sauce.
Then they started
planting the seed.
And so I started
ideating this --
bottling
and commercializing this,
my mom's hot sauce.
I came to the realization that
the current Mexican brands
or Hispanic brands here
in the United States
were not doing anything
to innovate.
We would bring innovation,
and we were trying to change
the perception
that Mexican food is unhealthy.
And that's when I decided
that Tia Lupita would become
more than just
a hot sauce brand.
It would become
a platform brand.
Hector, how many
years ago was that?
We started in 2019.
Tell us what your revenues are
for the last three years.
So in 2020,
we did $900,000.
-Wow.
Okay.
In 2021,
we did $1.5 million.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
And this year,
we're going to do $4 million.
Wow!
Are you profitable?
Last month was our
first profitable month.
Congrats. Congrats.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
We're very proud.
And where
are you selling?
We're in Sprouts nationally,
five regions of Whole Foods,
key regional accounts
from Wegmans to Walmart.
We have Target on site,
Publix.
Do you have to pay
to get listed there?
And, actually, last year, we
took a huge hit with slotting.
How big is that hit?
So in 2020,
we lost around $700K.
Okay.
Ohh.
In 2021, we lost $1.2.
Ooh, so how much have
you invested or brought in?
We've raised $1.9.
Corcoran: Wow.
There you have it.
$1.9 so far,
and now we're doing a full seed.
What percentage of the company
do you own?
I still own around 65%.
65%.
And how much of your own money
did you invest?
Around $700K.
Wow.
Wow. You're all in.
Good for you.
We did a line of credit
against our mortgage
and all that.
On your home?
Yeah, on our home.
Damn, Hector.
Yeah.
Well...
at projected
$4 million in sales,
you're doing
something right.
But I just don't like...
It's not that
I dislike Mexican food.
I just don't love it.
I don't believe that I would
have the passion to be able
to help you with this,
so I'm out.
Thank you so much, Daymond.
I appreciate it.
I think this is a long journey
and a cash-rich journey.
I don't think the 5%
for $500,000 is going
to get you there.
I'm out.
Thank you so much, Barbara.
Yeah, Hector,
I'm along the same lines.
I think
the tortillas were great,
but you're in a business
that's a grind.
I just don't see the numbers
working for me.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Absolutely. And so, Mark,
I appreciate that.
And we do have
a path of profitability.
We proved it last month.
Let's focus on that, Hector,
because you never told me
what it costs you
to make the product.
Right.
So walk me through
the cactus
grain-free sea salt.
Let's just go with this one.
What does it cost to make this?
Yeah, that bag
cost us $1.50.
Yes.
And then we retail it
between $3.99 and $4.99.
It's competitive with other
grain-free tortilla chips
out there.
I have been looking for
a product for Chef Wonderful
that's grain-free, 'cause that's
my whole shtick these days,
is healthier eating,
healthier living.
And this is one of the best
I've tasted,
I gotta tell you that.
But these numbers are tough.
They're very tough.
Hector, while he's thinking.
I'm going to jump in.
I think you've done
a really great job.
What concerns me, though,
is you have a lot of debt.
There's a lot going on
financially
that really worries me.
So for me,
it's not the right investment.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
As usual, all roads lead back
to Mr. Wonderful.
I've heard that
so many times.
Unfortunately,
so have we.
It's a tough deal.
I think you asked too much,
because Lori's right --
You got a ton of debt
on this thing,
and you've mortgaged your house,
which scares me.
If I can say one more thing,
I just want to
try to sell myself,
because I haven't had
the opportunity.
I've worked so hard
for these last four years.
They've been everything to me.
It's honoring not only
my culture, my heritage,
my mom, right?
Today, one month ago,
my dad passed away,
and I should have been there
with my mom right now
in his one-month memorial,
but I couldn't say no
to this opportunity.
It's been a journey,
but we're all in.
Okay,
here's an offer.
I'll give you
the $500,000 in debt.
It's going to be
36 months.
I'm going to do interest
at 12.5%, which is current.
Corcoran: Ouch.
Sorry. That's current.
That's market, Barbara.
Sorry.
Still ouch.
Yeah.
And I want 10% of the company.
Oof.
I'm taking a huge risk here,
Hector. Huge.
This is like
a line of credit you're...?
Yeah, I'll do it
as a line of credit.
You draw it down, but I want
first money back first.
Absolutely.
Are you allowed to
subordinate?
Are you able
to subordinate the debt?
Yes, absolutely. Yes.
Okay.
The concern here is the double
of the equity that I --
I understand that, Hector,
but you're asking me
to get behind this product
with my whole team, back you.
If I do this deal,
I can't do another one like it.
This is my deal
in this space,
so that's a decision
I have to make.
And, frankly, I'm not
getting out of bed for 5%,
Hector, I'm sorry.
You don't have
to do this deal,
but it's the only one
I'm going to do.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Shark are out.
Hector has an offer
from Kevin --
$500,000 as a line of credit
at 12.5% interest
for 10% of his grain-free
Mexican snack company,
Tia Lupita.
You don't have
to do this deal,
but it's the only one
I'm going to do, Hector.
Think you'd get a better deal
elsewhere, Hector,
speaking on your behalf.
That's a rich deal.
Well, you didn't make him
an offer, Barbara.
I was honest about that
right up front.
Barbara's right.
You wanted an offer on
"Shark Tank," you just got one.
You may not like it, but that's
why they call it the Shark Tank.
You can counter.
[ Sighs ]
Yeah. I mean, I think,
Mr. Wonderful, the 10%
is the only thing that is --
that is rattling me.
I don't know if
it's worth anything yet.
Do you know what it takes
to sell a company
in the snack area?
You gotta get to
$50 million
before any strategic's
even interested.
What are you
willing to give?
You knew we weren't
gonna for for 5%.
And, Hector, here's what
I'm also thinking --
You're going
to keep raising money.
I'm going to get diluted.
I mean, I've seen this movie
before, my friend.
If I start at 5%,
I'll have less than 1%
by the time you're finished
getting the $50 million.
Would you do the same deal
for 7.5%?
No.
I see the value of you
coming in, and, you know,
you would bring so much,
but I don't know
if that's the right deal
right now for me.
I'm different than
any investor you have.
He's more arrogant.
I'm sorry.
I know my value, Hector.
You gotta make a decision.
I'm not flexible.
Is there any flexibility
with the equity?
$500,000 -- I cry like a baby
when I lose $500,000.
Yeah.
I get on my knees
and I break down.
And it happens a lot.
[ Laughs ]
It never happens.
Well, it's a loan.
So why don't you
ask him for $750,000?
Is that a possibility?
Can I --
O'Leary: No!
Lori -- Lori didn't even
make you an offer.
Then why don't you
ask him for a million?
You can offer -- You can ask
for anything you want.
The answer's no.
Great deals,
both sides feel pain.
I'm feeling pain about $500,000
I'm putting at risk.
You're feeling pain
about the 10%
that doesn't have
any value yet.
Kevin, it's a loan.
How is it a risk?
Greiner:
Yeah, it's a loan.
It's the dilution.
He's gonna go issue shares.
I'm gonna pay you back.
That's diluting me down
from 10%.
Well, why don't you
make it non-dilutable?
I could do that,
but that would...
We can work that in. We'll make
your shares non-dilutable.
And you keep --
You'll stay at 5%.
In exchange for what?
I'll do the $500K as a line of
credit in exchange of 5%,
and that 5% that you own
will not get diluted.
Not bad.
So non-dilutable, yeah.
That's fair. Take the deal.
Lock in.
Mm.
That's a good deal right there
for you, Kevin.
Hector, you have a deal.
Yeah, Kevin!
O'Leary: Good job, Hector.
Ohh, yes!
Ahhhhhhhhhh!
Tortillas for everybody!
Mr. Wonderful,
it's a pleasure.
You, too, man.
Thank you so much.
Great, great.
That's really great.
Yes, thank you so much.
Congratulations, Hector.
Well done.
Thank you so much, guys.
I appreciate you.
♪♪
Yeah! [ Grunts ]
Negotiating with Kevin has been
one of the hardest things
I've ever done in my life.
He has all the leverage,
all the experience.
I mean, you know, that's why
he sits in the middle,
and he's been here
since the beginning.
I can't wait to work with him.
It's going to be
an amazing journey with him.
-- Captions by VITAC --
♪♪